hey everyone this is Steve with collider
um I am here in Park City at our
Sundance studio with the lovely folks
behind Sun Coast and uh I have a lot of
questions for you guys but before we get
started the only reason we get to be
here at Sundance being able to promote
movies and independent cinema is because
we have film EO as our sponsor I really
want to give them a huge thank you for
allowing us to be here um and if you're
not familiar with filo uh they're
shattering the barriers by placing the
power to Greenlight films in the hands
of creators and fans and you can learn a
lot more about them by visiting their
website at
film. how you guys doing great how are
you I'm doing very well I've learned a
lot about your cast we've talked about
Airlines airline miles what they're
working on um you know a lot of stuff
but listen I have a first of all
congratulations on your first feature
thank you so much so most people will
not have seen the most people watching
this right now will not have seen the
movie yet so how have you been
describing it to friends and family I
think it's you know it's a drama with a
lot of lightness and comedy in it you
know um it's it's about a teenage girl
who's coming of age in an environment
that's unique to someone um that is 17
her brother is in hospice he has a few
months left to live and he happens to be
at the same hospice as a woman named
Terry shyo who had a very big national
politicized uh case in Florida in 2005
where I happened to be at hospice with
my brother in 2005 at the same hospice
as Terry shyo so it's based on that but
um there's also a lot of invented
details about um this sort of Cinderella
Journey that this girl is going on she's
making friends for the first time who
are these lovely kids I mean adults
they're adults um but they're kids to me
um but these these lovely people uh and
uh and so this is where a lot of like
the joy and the light and the Heart
comes from is that this 17-year-old girl
is you know getting a crush for the
first time time and being accepted for
the first time and going out and
partying in nightclubs for the first
time um while also dealing with this
very serious thing at home so one of the
things that I commend you on is that um
it's very hard you have limited screen
time with the friends and all of you
guys feel like very individual
characters that all got to shine so can
you sort of talk about making sure you
have a you know what I mean giving
everyone those moments and for you guys
talk a little bit about the reaction
reading the script for the first time
and what you thought of it in your
emotional connection yeah I mean well it
was it was important to me that they
weren't just you know a stereotypical
teen blob you know I really I wanted
everybody to have a different point of
view um and I really wanted them to be
sort of more Protectors of Doris than um
what you might normally see them being
mean or judgmental I think they're for
the most part they're very like
protective and welcoming to her and that
was important to me yeah when I first
read the script I um I just I I fell in
love nothing came I I I read it and I
understood who Lacy was within like the
first scene um that I got in the
audition process and I just think that
yeah she you wrote just these characters
so incredibly well that it really took
no work to um you know bring it to life
at all yeah I mean me I when I first
read the script of course I cried like a
baby and it's just wild that these words
can have so much power when they're just
this these little black like thingies on
a white you know and it makes you ball
and then you're in your room after and
you're like ah so yeah but um I think
also every time I read one of my
characters lines Britney I was like wow
I know this girl who's just like this
and I know this girl who would say this
and I almost was like audibly speaking
my lines out before even having the role
um it was just so so realistic and yet
so poignant and you know funny oh oh my
gosh I me I think what Laura does so
well is she writes characters that are
real and human and everybody has a
little bit of good in them and a little
bit of bad and there's not a single
protagonist or antagonist they all have
such layers in dimension um and I think
even with my character Megan like she's
maybe like the meanest to Doris but it's
not coming from a place of just being
stereotypically mean like with her it's
coming from insecurity and she feels bad
about herself and it's like she has
layers to her it's not this
stereotypical mean girl um she's deeper
than that I think all of them are deeper
than that I think it's hard to do when
you have such a big cast but Laura did
it so perfectly gave every single person
such a beautiful story which as an actor
I'm so appreciative of yeah yeah for me
when I first read the script I was
actually with my mom and my dad we were
at I think some rooftop like restaurant
or something like that and I was reading
through it and I was like wow like I was
talking to about parents just telling
them like I I kind of talk a little bit
like this and it it just seems like this
character is it's not exactly who I am
but I also like you said like I know
people that are like this but then also
I felt so comfortable with the role and
that's for me personally that's not
really too easy to do like it didn't
feel like a character it felt like a
person that I was playing which I love
mhm yeah so uh one of the things that
you did such a great job with is uh the
way Laura plays
um essentially your quote unquote mom um
you know not really but you know what I
mean um and but she has to you she's
both difficult and loving and she
doesn't you know what I mean you get
frustrated with her but you understand
where she's coming from so can you sort
of talk about writing the role and also
Laura's performance cuz she really
threads that needle she's incredible um
I mean Laura is so incredible she Laura
is just this Rare Breed this this person
who can do this thing that you know
she's saying things that are kind of
hard to hear she's behaving in a way
that you're like oh just be nicer to
your daughter but at the same time
there's so much Humanity just pouring
out of her face you know you just love
her and you you see where this woman's
coming from her She's losing her son you
know like these are very real emotions
and um and the way that anyone would be
the character is not my mother I mean my
my mom and I had a totally different you
know journey and story um but it was you
know it was in an effort to capture a
lot of the emotions I felt as a a
teenager who is not getting the same
amount of attention as the sick kid you
know who's being forgotten and feeling
like that like and and and how to
capture six years of illness with my
brother into like an hour and a half
movie um and so that was where Christine
came and she's sort of this Powerhouse
um in a way to capture all those
emotions um but she's amazing I mean the
whole cast like with these kids too like
there was only one like there was only
one you know we audition tons of people
and then you're just like that is
Britney and that is Megan like there
there was no deciding you know like so
with every one of the these roles it's
like it felt like everybody put on this
second skin and became these people in a
way that was so rewarding and magical so
this is for all of you guys um you
obviously have a limited shooting
schedule you know what's in front of you
uh you see the shooting schedule what is
the day you have in your brain circled
in terms of I am so excited to film this
or oh my God I'm so nervous to film this
that's a great question that's a
wonderful question actually the one oh
go you do it the club scene I was so I'm
I'm underage so I was like ah yeah we're
going to be in the club no not actually
well she was 17 you were 17 yeah very
very
underage well I just mean not 21 I mean
21 is like so far from 21 17 and of
course like I was actually you know a
fake sneaking into the club and with the
bouncer and I'd got the whole experience
which was really fun I won't ever be
doing that again um yeah
so so that was I mean I just remember
looking forward to it and I remember the
outfit was crazy and yet I was still
really excited to wear it so what about
you guys though I don't know I looked
forward to every single day I've never
felt such peace on set um Laura had made
the space incredibly comfortable and um
just made you feel very confident in
your choices and what you were doing and
I've just really I I've worked with
amazing people but I've just really
never felt um so comforted and um
accepted and it was just an incredible
feeling and I loved going to set every
single day cuz I come back to the um the
house afterwards and I just be like I'm
like I really didn't I was just there
and I was just having fun and I didn't
usually I'm like in my head about none
of that MH and it felt great yeah yeah I
for me I would say I was most excited
and a little bit nervous about the like
the party scene that you'll see uh we're
we're all like playing Jenga playing
different games and doing maybe certain
things that we probably shouldn't be
doing like that was was a lot I was
nervous for it like you know certain
things certain clothes might be off you
never know you guys see mov but yeah
yeah it it was funny though but it was
very very fun I remember I was talking
to my mom and my dad about it and I was
like yo guess what I got to film like
this day they were like what so
yeah um oh that's such a good question I
have no idea I really loved the
sleepover scene with the girls I think
that was just such a sweet scene we had
so much fun like we were sitting down we
had actual popcorn and M&M's and snacks
ice cream it was really fun in your
pajamas they were in their pajamas it
was like I was like you guys know we're
still working right never felt like work
it was like we're just having we all
love each other so much and we would
just sit and that that day I remember I
just I loved it so much it was like we
were just giggling in between takes
having the best time yeah for for as a
director uh looked forward to or the
thing that you were really excited to
film or the thing you were really
nervous to film gosh I mean every day I
was really excited and really nervous um
um I feel like what was I mean I know
the ending scenes are very emotional you
know and and so those were scenes that
we really as a whole crew and cast and
everybody we were like we're not talking
about those scenes we're not putting
pressure on those scenes we're not going
to talk about what goes on in those
scenes you know like we're just going to
let those scenes unfold and it was a
really like Sacred Space that that our
first ad held that everybody held we did
you know private personals just me and
the actors like really tried to keep it
um organic and and not feeling like oh
you have to have this emotional reaction
in order to succeed today you know like
it was really important that that was
not placed on especially young Nico um
and uh and she's just such a like
organic natural talent and what pours
out of her is like lightning in a bottle
you know and so it was it was all about
making sure that she was so safe and
protected and those were definitely
scenes we waited till the very end of
the schedule so everyone you know was as
comfortable as they possibly could be
with each other and you really see it
when Laura and um and and Nico in that
in that final scene together you really
see this like I mean that that to me was
the most important scene of the movie
when they rejoin and um yeah that was
definitely one that I was like okay we
Circle this this is a Sacred Space so um
I love talking about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so for you you uh you get in the editing
room what were some of the surprises
that happened that you didn't expect
going in our editor okay so Sarah Shaw
and shout out to her she's not at
Sundance she wants to be um she's an
angel and a genius and um she's amazing
we spent you know such a long time in
post together and we had this luxury and
search light was so supportive and that
we really got to like experiment with
things and play and um you know we
removed some scenes that I really loved
like individually like loved those
scenes but I think when you look at when
you looked at the whole thing as a whole
it was like affecting different arcs and
pulling maybe watering something down
that didn't need to be um so that was
surprising to me the amount of scenes
that we pulled out of the movie and how
much that strengthened the movie um but
I mean Sarah and I just got so creative
and some someday uh we'll show the two
and a half hour editor
assembly of this movie uh it's very
different yeah well I was going to say
with something like that with like an
because uh and people that don't realize
an assembly cut is where you put like
everything in but like with that 2 and a
half hour version was that a version you
were like happy with or you're like oh
no so you know what's funny is they call
it the suicide cut right they're like
you're going to watch this and you are
going to want to end it all right that's
what every director told me they were
like you're going to watch the 's
assembly and you're going to want to
move to a different country and quit the
business um and I was I was very
prepared you know and so I was like I
saw the runtime and I was like oh 2
hours and 35 minutes like this is the
Titanic you know or Titanic Nova um and
um and and I was this is a long movie
and um so but I sat down I watched the
whole thing and I really was like it's
there you know I was never like oh no
what is this it's there I mean the
performances were all there like
everything it was so clear that it just
stuff needed to come out um but I I
never felt like hopeless or sad or
depressed I was very heartened by the
editor's assembly so um I like throwing
a curveball every once in a while and
here's the curveball question and uh for
all of you because you're also an actor
um if someone has never seen and it if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before what is the thing you'd like
them watching first and why and it could
be this film but it could be something
else Sun Coast yeah Sun
Coast Sun Coast yeah I'm not but sun
it's so very good and you will just not
regret the time you spend watching um I
definitely want to touch on the fact
that you guys are at Sun Dan but you're
also going to be in theaters and you're
going to be on Hulu like pretty soon is
it what is this like for you guys
because I'm sure when you're making it
you're like you never know what's going
to happen like I you know it could go
anywhere or it could just not ever come
out so what is it like to be premiering
at Sundance and going to theaters and
being on Hulu and this whole Whirlwind I
I'm I'm in a total dream I don't know
about yall I feel like I'm not
here I mean it's it's really been an
outof body experience I mean I feel like
every single person who worked on this
movie gave their whole selves to it like
truly I mean it was such a collaborative
experience and everyone just busted
their ass and cared so much about
telling the story so the fact that
people are going to get to see it and
that all those 100 plus people their
hard work and Blood Sweat and Tears is
going to be viewed by audiences is so
exciting so amazing um and um yeah and
and going to be in theaters uh you know
I think this movie on a big screen is
such an experience SD Heim our composer
with her partner Chris stracy they you
know they they the music that is in this
movie is incredible and when you see it
in a theater and when you see these kids
and the humor and the colors of Florida
and the emotional ending and Nico
Parker's genius and Laura Linny and
Woody harelson like it just feels like a
a movie theater movie you know um and so
I'm I'm so thrilled that people are
going to get a chance to see it that way
yeah I'm not sure if anyone wants to add
anything no yeah it does feel like a
dream it really does I have really big
reactions and I screamed when my team
told me they got in I was like I just
couldn't believe it I was like it's such
an like that's it's a huge thing like
this is huge and it's it's such an honor
just to be a part of it yep um I I have
to wrap with you guys but just real
quick um for soon to be fans of the film
what do you think they would be
surprised to learn about the making of
this movie
do y got anything well we didn't
actually film it in 2005 I don't know
but yeah also we lived through H
hurricane yeah we did we filmed in
Charleston we filmed in Charleston yeah
and which hurricane was it hurricane Ian
I'll never forget you Ian and we
literally we had to evacuate to like a
hotel we all went to a hotel together
and we lived in the same building for a
few days and we would like come
downstairs and meet up and play card
games and like so many games and and it
was that was also like like I hate
hurricanes but it was a bonding
experience for us also and to like go
through that together but yeah we live
through a hurricane that's actually a
good a good behind the scenes fact on
that note for everyone watching uh uh
obviously uh I really recommend for
everyone checking this film out and
thank you so much for coming in and I
also want to give a huge thank you one
more time to filo for being our sponsor
because it's allowing us to be here at
Sundance uh thank you so much for coming
in thank you so for and have have a
great great great Sundance thank you
for